Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis Thierry Toutin
et je suis artisan de la lumière.
C’est-à-dire que j’ai décidé de travailler
cette onde comme une matière première
en fabriquant des objets lumineux.
Je vous emmène avec moi dans la lumière,
celle qui se ressent, celle des émotions,
en luminophilie.
Mais avant tout, c’est quoi la lumière ?
Parce qu'il y a plusieurs
façons de la définir.
Il y a la scientifique
avec ses photons, sa vitesse.
Passionnant.
La pratique, pour éclairer votre bureau,
vous admirer dans la salle de bain.
Et il y a celle qui nous intéresse,
celle qui parle directement
à nos sens, sans un mot.
La golden hour, par exemple.
Quand le soleil va se coucher
et qu’il prend ses teintes jaune orangé.
Vous paraissez plus bronzé,
tout est magnifié,
alors que finalement,
rien n’a changé dans le décor,
seule la lumière est différente.
Ce qui se passe à ce moment-là est
important, car vous êtes transformé.
Vos préoccupations ont changé.
Vous êtes plus apaisé, réceptif,
vous êtes bien.
C’est cette lumière qui nous intéresse,
c’est celle qui nous fait vibrer
et monter en nous quelque chose de beau.
Pour prendre un autre exemple
avec la nature,
que ressentez-vous quand
une grosse pluie se prépare ?
Quand tout devient sombre,
gris, fade, sans relief,
puis, quand la lumière revient,
qu’elle reflète sur les nuages, vive,
explosant de couleurs chaudes ?
On est mieux là.
On observe ce tableau réjouissant
et ce moment est indescriptible -
et c’est juste mon job.
Enfin, tenter de l’approcher un peu,
de concevoir des objets lumineux
qui captent votre attention
et vous font vous arrêter un moment,
comme suspendu dans le temps.
Mais avant tout, c’est quoi la lumière ?
(Applaudissements)
Merci, merci beaucoup.
Un orage ou un coucher de soleil,
c’est naturel et c’est inégalable.
Mais nous pouvons nous aussi
tenter de faire des choses.
On peut s’amuser, on peut expérimenter,
mais pour ça, avant, il faut apprendre
à voir la lumière, en prendre conscience.
C’est ma matière première,
c’est celle que j’ai choisi de travailler,
car j’y suis sensible depuis toujours,
je crois.
Ma chambre d'ado était lumineuse,
ça clignotait beaucoup.
En un clic, je tamisais l’appartement -
j’ai séduit mon épouse
comme ça, d’ailleurs.
Je travaillais également de nuit
dans une clinique
et je me sentais agressé
par la froideur des éclairages.
Vous savez, ces néons qui sont couleur
blanc industrie, blanc du jour.
Avec ce type d’éclairage,
vous avez le teint livide,
même en pleine santé.
Essayez de mettre ça dans votre salon
et à la première soirée avec des amis,
vous allez ressentir comme un malaise.
Si, en plus, cette lumière tombe
directement du plafond,
alors vous avez carrément créé
une ambiance lugubre.
J’ai compris au fil du temps
que la décoration de nos intérieurs
est importante.
C’est notre endroit,
c’est notre cocon protecteur.
Mais c’est aussi l’endroit où l’on reçoit,
où l’on montre qui nous sommes.
Si la lumière est mal prise en compte,
on se prive d’une dimension.
Et on passe à côté de la femme de sa vie.
Au fur et à mesure que j’avançais
sur mon chemin lumineux,
l’idée de créer des luminaires
se précisait.
En effet, quoi de plus logique
que de faire des luminaires
lorsqu’on aime faire
des ambiances lumineuses ?
J’y suis allé à tâtons au début,
puis j’ai pris confiance.
C’est devenu à ce moment-là une évidence.
Il fallait que j’agisse parce que
je savais soigner les ambiances.
Je voulais en faire un métier,
je voulais en faire mon métier.
En fait, je voulais faire des luminaires
avec de l'émotion dedans.
Parce que faire des luminaires,
c’est bien,
mais le faire avec l’intention
d’y mettre toute son âme,
c’est autrement plus exaltant, non ?
Alors concrètement, comment
travaille-t-on la lumière dans un objet ?
Avec de l’envie, de la détermination,
des nuits blanches,
il faut être obsédé par sa création.
En fait, au début, je ne savais pas faire.
J’étais déjà bricoleur,
mais je ne savais pas faire de luminaires.
Et je savais encore moins
faire de la lumière.
J’y étais simplement sensible.
Cette envie m’a donc poussé
à comprendre les phénomènes
qui interagissent avec la lumière.
En effet, elle peut se diffuser
au travers d’une porcelaine,
elle peut miroiter sur un métal poli.
Elle peut se refléter
sur une cloche en verre,
être dispersée par un moucharabieh.
Je pourrais encore continuer
comme ça à un moment.
Quand vous explorez
les possibilités de la lumière,
vous vous rendez compte
de tous les états qu’elle peut offrir.
Il y a d’ailleurs tellement de mots
qui les décrivent comme :
éblouissante, rayonnante, brillante.
Plus doux : chatoyante,
ondoyante, scintillante.
Presque absente : pénombre, clarté, lueur.
J’ai de la chance,
mon inspiration est facile à trouver.
Il me suffit de regarder autour de moi,
de regarder la nature.
Parfois une idée naît
en pleine nuit où, juste comme ça,
sans raison apparente, elle est là.
Le problème avec les idées :
c’est qu’elles se bousculent
et s’entrechoquent.
Elles sont trop nombreuses.
Il faut faire des choix.
Mais quand cette idée s’impose
à moi, qu’elle me plaît,
alors, je la travaille
comme un diamant brut.
Je l'observe sous tous les angles
pour déceler tous les éclats.
Je tente différentes approches
pour en tailler les plus belles facettes.
Et quand cette idée est devenue concrète,
que je décide de la fabriquer,
tout un processus entre alors en action.
La fabrication de cette poésie
en trois dimensions
n’est encore que purement hypothétique.
Il faut passer par une phase physique,
prendre en compte les aspects
purement techniques.
Il faut garder les pieds bien sur terre.
Il faut donc avant apprendre à ressentir
Tout ce travail n’est encore que virtuel
et tous ces efforts peuvent
se traduire par rien.
Il faut être honnête :
des fois, c’est loupé.
Et tout ce travail qui part à la poubelle,
c’est assez rageant.
En fait, vous ne pouvez qu’imaginer
votre œuvre, uniquement la fantasmer.
D’ailleurs, la réalité, en plus, est
souvent différente de votre concept.
Elle évolue au fur et à mesure,
comme si elle vivait sa propre vie.
Mais quand ce... Merci.
Mais quand vient ce moment
d’allumer pour la première fois,
que les clairs obscurs, les ombres
portées, les reflets s’installent,
qu’une émotion vient vous bousculer
sur votre chaise,
ces premiers instants
qui couronnent votre travail
vous procurent un sentiment
absolument grisant.
Vous redevenez un petit garçon
le matin de Noël.
Avec le temps, mon ressenti
s’est affiné, s’est précisé.
Je suis devenu plus conscient
de mes possibilités
et j’ai développé
une sorte de savoir-faire.
Voici une illustration
de ce que je fais maintenant.
J’aime mettre en scène des objets lumineux
avec pour but de mettre en lumière
ce qui les rend exceptionnels.
Voici des pampilles
qui ont été accumulées durant des années
au petit bonheur la chance.
Elles ont fini oubliées dans une boîte à
chaussures, faute de savoir quoi en faire.
Elles étaient dépareillées.
C'était difficile de les mettre en valeur.
J’ai donc décidé d’en faire autre chose
que ce que l’on s’attend à voir
avec des pampilles.
Elles ont repris place
et donnent à nouveau tout leur éclat.
Le propriétaire les a redécouvertes
sous ce nouvel angle avec un vrai plaisir.
Ou encore cette lampe à huile qui était
devenue disgracieuse, peu fonctionnelle.
Avec le temps, elle avait perdu son aura,
ce pour quoi elle existait.
La dame qui en a hérité me l’a confiée,
ne sachant qu’en faire.
Elle m’a laissé carte blanche
pour en tirer le meilleur.
J’ai donc décidé de n’en garder que son
cœur, son âme, ce qui en fait son essence.
La lumière permet de faire ressortir des
petites subtilités invisibles autrement.
Elle permet de mettre le doigt
sur cette petite chose qui vous touche,
mais qui est assez indéfinissable et qui
n'appartient qu'à l'histoire de cet objet.
Et donc à celle de son propriétaire.
En fait, elle met en valeur les émotions.
Un autre aspect de mon métier
est de fabriquer des luminaires.
Le but est de rendre
presque tangible cette lumière.
Je considère mon travail réussi lorsque
vous pouvez regarder longtemps cet objet
et vous perdre dans vos pensées.
J'aime penser qu'il y a
un lien entre vous.
Un peu comme pour les sons,
les harmoniques,
ces vibrations qui, à une certaine
fréquence, deviennent agréables.
Pour la lumière, ça s’en approche.
Elle vous offre un moment de détente,
un moment de flottement,
un moment entre parenthèses.
Je suis comme un luthier
qui accorderait un luminaire
pour qu’il vibre avec vous à l’unisson.
Ce cube que j’ai apporté,
si vous pouviez le voir de près,
il est composé de couleurs
qui forment des méandres,
des formes abstraites.
Il y participe.
La lumière de ce cube oscille comme une
respiration, comme un battement de cœur.
Il participe à ce moment passé entre nous.
Il est un point de mire et il attire
votre attention depuis le début.
Il m'aide à créer cette ambiance
lumineuse qui m'est si chère.
Il m’aide à vous dire
que j’aime la lumière,
à surpasser ma réserve naturelle
et à sortir de mon atelier
pour vous partager ce lien
que j’ai avec cette matière
qui n’est pas tout à fait
comme les autres.
La lumière n'est pas que fonctionnelle.
Elle façonne notre vision.
Elle n'est pas que technique.
Elle donne du relief aux gens
qui nous entourent.
Elle agit sur notre bonheur.
J'aurais pu choisir de devenir
éclairagiste pour le spectacle,
d’illuminer nos villes,
nos bâtiments historiques,
mais j’ai choisi nos intérieurs,
car je ne sais soigner que
les ambiances lumineuses intimes.
Mon ambition est de créer
des objets délicats,
poétiques, romantiques,
pour que la fonction
s’efface devant l’émotion.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)